since President Trump took office
there's been of course a lot of negative
news about our relationship with Mexico
and Mexican immigration well I wanted to
take things in a more positive direction
so here's the plan tomorrow I am flying
to Mexico City where I'm gonna rent a
television studio and shoot an episode
of our show with the help of an all
Mexican staff crew gasps and studio
audience we're calling it Conan Without
Borders made in Mexico yeah it's like
going over to the neighbor's house for a
while oh it's really nice we're gonna go
down there and meet make a lot of
friends and I just found this out today
this was exciting this is absolutely
real a talk show host named hey soos
Guzman put together a video to welcome
me to Mexico and it features Mexican
celebrities and then regular people on
the street all doing an impression of
yours truly this is real we didn't make
this up this is real and it it may be
very happy take a look Coenen estos
nuestra forma de decirte
VA merida mexico cannot mean can't it
doesn't make you cover your Manito
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
why is that the international symbol
it's my own fault that that's the
internet you'll sort it on yourself I
brought that on myself I can't play them
I do thank everyone involved in doing
that and I love the spirit yeah that was
really sweet so it's gonna be I think a
really good show Kona without borders
made in Mexico will air on Wednesday
March 1st at 10 p.m. right here on TBS
[Music]
[Applause]
you